I'm in Rio de Janeiro in Brazil I've
come here to meet Brazilian chemists and
to go to conference but I'd been really
struck by something which I wanted to
share with you
Brazil is very famous across the world
for the use of bio ethanol this is
ethanol that is made by fermenting sugar
to use as a fuel for cars behind me is a
gas station which is selling ethanol as
a car fuel not pure ethanol but ethanol
with only a small percentage of gasoline
added to it I had a vision and I had
been told that most cars in Brazil use
ethanol as a fuel the argument is that
sugarcane makes sugar with co2 from the
atmosphere and sunlight so when you
ferment this sugar and make ethanol when
you burn the ethanol in your car engine
the co2 just goes back to the atmosphere
so you don't add any co2 to the
atmosphere whereas if you burn ordinary
gasoline you're taking oil from under
the ground and burning it and putting
extra co2 in the atmosphere everybody
holds up Brazil is a great example to
the world on how you should be using
biofuels to fuel your cars but and now
this is where the big surprise came I
already knew that ethanol was not as
good a few as gasoline you don't get so
many kilometers per liter or miles per
gallon when you burn ethanol because it
doesn't contain so much carbon in a
liter as you do gasoline but what I
didn't realize is because the price of
sugar is quite high ethanol has a price
which is very similar to that of
gasoline itself if you look at the
notice outside the garage there isn't
much difference in the price at all a
few years ago cars in Brazil would run
either on ethanol or on gasoline so if
you had an ethanol
you had to buy ethanol in the last few
years new engines have been developed
they call them flexed engines which can
run either on gasoline or on ethanol so
when you go into the gas station you
look at the price and decide is it
better to buy gasoline or ethanol and
apparently at the moment although the
gas stations are selling ethanol people
are buying more and more gasoline
because they think it's more
cost-effective their money goes further
they get more miles for their rayel for
their unit of money so I was completely
surprised I had the vision of all these
cars fuelled by ethanol but in fact
they're mostly running on gasoline so I
think the message from this is the
ethanol works really well but if you're
going to introduce new fuels you need to
think about people's behavior as well as
just the science behind it and in the
end wherever people are all over the
world they're always going to try and
get the best value for their money and
so if new fuels aren't as good or better
from the point of view of money people
are not going to use them as much as
they should
the problem for all of this and why the
price comes into it is because sugar can
also be used for food and when sugar is
in demand and the price is high then the
ethanol is also has a high price what we
need a so-called second generation
ethanol which is made not from the sugar
but from the cellulose the other parts
of the plant which at the moment can't
be used for anything except to be burnt
or used for compost if we can begin to
start turning cellulose into ethanol
then there will not be the conflict
between food and fuel and the price
should be considerably lower you don't
have to use sugar you can use all sorts
of different grains in America they use
maize sweet corn for making ethanol and
that from the food point of view is even
worse because before ethanol production
started nearly all of the corn harvest
was used for food and now much of it has
been diverted for using for biofuels but
in the end we have no choice
oil is going to run out I'm not sure
when but at some stage we're going to
need to use tools made from biomass
you